نريد جميعًا معرفة سر الحصول على بشرة أفضل بشكل
جيد ، فقد يكون بالفعل على
رف الحمام الخاص بك ، ربما رأيت
أشخاصًا يقومون بهذا الاتجاه عبر الإنترنت
نوعًا من تدوير المنتجات المختلفة
التي يستخدمونها لجعلها أكثر
فاعلية قليلاً كريستينا فيتزباتريك
معي Dove  في أعماق هذا الروتين الحيوي للعناية بالبشرة ،
هذه أخبار رائعة إذا كنت
مثلي ، لدي الكثير منهم
جالسين بشكل صحيح ، نعم متى وأين
تستخدمهم وأنت تعلم أنني أعتقد أن
مفتاح البشرة الجيدة قد تعلمناه جميعًا من
الآن هو روتين مختلف قليلاً ،
إنه مفهوم يسمى دورة الجلد ،
إنه لا يستخدم فقط
منتجات معينة ولكنه أيضًا ينتبه
إلى الترتيب الذي تستخدمه بها ،
مما يسمح لبشرتك بأخذ قسط من الراحة إذا
كنت ترغب في جعل الطريقة شائعة  بواسطة
طبيب الأمراض الجلدية الدكتورة ويتني بو ،
تحتاج بشرتك فعليًا إلى أيام التعافي
بنفس الطريقة التي تفعل بها عضلاتك إذا
كنت ستستخدم الريتينول ذات
ليلة وستستخدم حمض ألفا هيدروكسي
في الليلة التالية ،  د في
ليلتين للتعافي
، تقول إنه يمكنك التفكير في الأمر
كإيقاف مؤقت للدفع وقفة الإيقاع يقترح الدكتور بو
هذا النمط الليلي الأول يقشر
بشرتك ليلًا ، ثم ضع
ريتينويد أو ريتينول مضادًا للشيخوخة ثم تترك
بشرتك تستعيد عافيتها لمدة ليلتين  باستخدام
مرطب فقط تحدثنا إلى
طبيبة الأمراض الجلدية الدكتورة ميشيل هنري
وسألنا لماذا هذا
الاتجاه الفيروسي يثير إعجاب المحترفين ،
لذلك مع ركوب الدراجات الجلدية ، ما نقوم به هو
أننا نكسر حقًا
تقديمك للمكونات النشطة
التي أحبها.  توفير إطار عمل
للمضي ببطء حقًا لأن
الاتجاه الحالي في العناية بالبشرة هو أن تكون
أكثر عدوانية قليلاً وأرى الكثير من
الطفح الجلدي الكثير من التهيج والكثير من
الضغط من مرضاي
لأنهم لا يتبعون هذا النهج البطيء
تقول الدكتورة هنري إن سببًا آخر لإعجابها
لركوب الدراجات الجلدية هو أنه يسمح لك
ببناء قدرتك على التحمل بمرور الوقت
ثم إضافة منتجات أخرى تدريجيًا إذا
اخترت ذلك ، فربما يمنحك هذا النهج.
النتائج التي تبحث
عنها عندما يتعلق الأمر ببشرة متوهجة صحية
بالطبع الأمر كله يتعلق بالحفاظ
على الروتين وربما لا تستخدم
الكثير من المنتجات التي تعتقد أنه يجب عليك
استخدامها كل ليلة وألا تكون
عدوانيًا جدًا كما سمعت  هذا صحيح فيما يتعلق
بمنتجات الشعر أيضًا ، لذا سنرى سأحاول
أن تشكرك كريستينا على الترحيب بك